what's up guys if you're not subscribed
Please Subscribe also please smash that
like button on the video and enjoy the
show there are people that say there are
four forces of nature there's
electricity and magnetism that's one
force now it used to be two Force now
it's one force there's something called
the weak nuclear force this is
responsible for radioactive decay so
when a when a neutron decays and shoots
off an electron a neutrino ant nutrino
and and a proton those objects are are
part of what's called weak nuclear Decay
okay then there's a strong force of
electromagnetism uh sorry a strong force
of the nucleus which is responsible you
ever think of like how does I don't
think most people think about this but
helium has two protons in its nucleus
neut you never well we're going to see
the the Macy's day parade soon so when
you see the helium balloon think about
the fact that helium has two protons in
its nucleus okay what do you know about
like charges Julian not much assume
nothing like charges repel what do you
know about opposites Oh I thought you
said light charges not like like like
yeah they repel attract so how does this
proton how these two protons stick
together they both positively
charge we would have to break that mold
well you'd have to have some other Force
that's stronger than the electrostatic
repulsion between two like charges and
that's called the strong force it indeed
exists then there's the fourth Force
which you're very familiar with because
you're you know you're jacked right
that's called gravity so you're working
against gravity you go to the gym you do
what the question is can we unify more
those forces we already unified
electricity and magnetism into one force
so we basically reduced five forces to
four forces then they reduced another
force in the 60s and 70s one of my past
guests Sheldon glashow inspiration for
young Sheldon on The you know the Big
Bang Theory oh [__] really yeah um so
he's a noal Oran up in Boston he and his
colleagues Steven Weinberg and Abdus
Salam they uh invented a way to unify
together the weak nuclear force with the
electric and magnetic force and that's
called Electro weak Theory Theory so now
we've reduced five forces down to two
down to three Electro weak and then
gravity and the strong nuclear force
okay now the question is can you unify
the strong nuclear force with the
Electra weak Force that's called Grand
unified theory if those were shown to be
the manifestation of one single Force
then you'd have two left guess what we'd
want to do next unify a strong plus
Electro weak with gravity that's called
The Theory of Everything that in some
sense is the unification that Eric
attempts to achieve and that string
theory attempts to achieve so they're
trying to achieve the ultimate
unification but wait there's a problem
it would be like we built the second and
third floor of this Penthouse apartment
here but we never built the basement or
the first floor in other words we have
not yet come to an agreement or any
testable theory for what's called Grand
unification abbreviation gut so I always
joke back to my hilarious joke yeah the
toe before the gut putting a toe before
the gut and I do that on a scale cuz I
can't look down but but if you look at
these
phenomena why is there an obsession with
this and I think it's because of what
your B past guest Mito said if you could
get this equation perhaps one inch long
I'm going to try to channel M perhaps
one inch long it could take you to the
top you would then have known and
knowledge of the mind of God yes that's
why he calls it that but wait a second
how can you know the mind of God if you
don't know his like packs and his and
his Cranium cuz you don't have the gut
you don't have the gut Mito so why are
you doing that why because what did he
say inspired him the most on this very
chair in this very type of Studio when
you were down he said Einstein he said
when he died he noted that Einstein had
on his desk a piece of paper and he was
working so hard and it was to come up
with this Theory of Everything it's not
really what he was doing he certainly
wasn't doing String Theory what he was
referring to it as yeah yeah I mean it
was his it was his holy grail his
promised land and Mito wanted to not
take over well we don't have a grand
unified theory if Mito had come up at as
an age whatever he was when Einstein
died I want to be a theoretical
physicist and understand how to unify
together the strong nuclear force with
the electromagnetic force he would have
won probably multiple Nobel prizes and
also did what Einstein didn't do but
because of this Allure of being the next
Einstein and so forth people like h and
and others have built up people like Ed
Whitten into these superhuman intellects
that almost too much is invested in for
it to not be right there's no evidence
for it that was the guy that Eric was in
in that same sit down with Joe Rogan
when he talked about miio Whitten was
the guy who he was like I am so
intimidated by this man he's so smart or
whatever and but he hasn't he's
Voldemort he's he's another guy who's
smack in the middle of of Defending
strength Theory well he's one of the
foremost you know progenitors of of one
of the closest and key insights of
string theory which is originally the
string theory had 26 Dimensions I would
say can we break it down for people Str
yeah so String Theory uh is a
mathematical uh conception that attempts
to do uh a unification of quantum
mechanics which is the theory of the
atomic world in the realm of the
electrons and protons and crout no the
electrons and neutrons and so forth and
their con constituent particles
including things like quarks and then uh
and then combine them in a uh
unification schema to make them
compatible with gravity to have a
particle of gravity effectively that
acts on the space this very esoteric
mathematical space and for technical
reasons you can't do it in the Ordinary
World of three-dimensional space that
you and I love and enjoy combined with
time so time plus space is called space
time it is a network of points
mathematically arbitrarily speaking
that there is not enough space so to
speak there's not enough degrees of
freedom to have all the particles come
together and manifest gravity with the
particles of charge electromagnetism the
particles of the weak force and the
particles of the strong force in four
dimensions orig they go below it they go
a l they go above it they they they say
actually the space in which things are
happening is not four we see
four-dimensional space just like we
don't see the effects of protons
neutrons and electrons but we will see
we will see the macros OPC manifestation
of uh of particles we see their
Collective Behavior we can't see their
individual Behavior they will say you
can't even see the individual behavior
of the dimensions because they're
they're so much smaller there their
thigh scales in which they operate are
so far removed from our observability
that's what I was talking about go lower
with the size yeah exactly right so so
you're effectively uh talking about uh
uh what are different schemes called
compactification and so forth so you
have more than the four dimensions now
the question is is it five dimensions
there were theories in other words you
could have a theory that would have
quantum mechanics and magnetism and
electricity and that actually could work
in a certain sense if SpaceTime had five
Dimensions um so if you had one more
Dimension it's kind of you'd have like
an electromagnetic Dimension and you can
almost see this with things like there
are birds or here's a good thing like
there there's three properties to light
like we're in this room there's certain
color of light there's a certain
intensity of light and there's something
called polarization which is the least
familiar property of light which is how
the waves of electricity and magnetism
are Marching up and down left and right
or not at all okay yeah I never thought
about that building this thought about
the first two exactly it's totally
unfamiliar because we don't have sensors
to detect that bees do bees do and
there's certain crystals that can have
the sense and birds do so they can
navigate there's certain navigational
properties that nature has embodied them
to involve to have such that they can
navigate using the not just the color
and intensity of the Sun but actually
when the sun is down they'll be able to
navigate based on the polarization of
the lights waves but anyway if you add
another dimension our eyes to our eyes
capability and and actually then we
could see this phenomena it would be
like yeah we're adding an extra
Dimension to SpaceTime so we'd have we'd
have super uh what do they call that
extra sensory perception six sense um so
so we don't have that technically
there's a tiny amount in certain people
but but anyway the average person
doesn't have it so when you uh think
about what they had to do they had to
say well well what is the uh minimum
number of additional properties of the
universe that you'd have to add such
that it could manifest the properties
that you do want which is to have
quantum mechanics and gravity play
together nicely and all operate as one
single equation one single force field
and that was found to be originally 26
you need 26 different dimensions of
space and then these these abstract
spaces that we can't by definition
access because we're we exist in three
dimensions and even particles of light
only travel in three dimensions of space
in one in time so you'd have to have
some other way to access these
dimensions and and then the obser the
immediate observations we don't see any
of these Dimensions so there must be
either way too big for us to see we're
just these tiny little ants on the
surface of a doughnut and we don't know
that the doughnut is curving in this
direction or that direction or the um or
it's the opposite where these enormous
macroscopic creatures and actually the
SpaceTime is curved in these
phenomenally infinitesimally small
dimensions of 10us 30th CM that we can't
also not access we can't detect them
there's no properties of particle
accelerators there's no microscope that
can zoom in as you say to see them now
what Whitten did is he realized that
there was a way to reduce that number
from 26 to 11 and then it was reduced to
10 Dimensions how um so this is truly
Beyond even my mathematical you know uh
Concepts but uh but effectively as I
understand it the compactification was a
recognition that there the instan ation
of these particles the the properties of
particles or the properties of these
strings they didn't need to be have at
that many dimensions the original number
of dimensions and so this was basically
what one him the fields metal there's no
know about priz in mathematics the
closest thing is is called the fields
metal and it's it's awarded to people
under 40 for the greatest contribution
uh to mathematics and he won it for
physics basically for this for these
kind of uh laws and understanding how
you could reduce the dimensionality down
to a more tractable number I always say
like over the summer there was this big
brewhaha with um you know that Joe Rogan
and Elon Musk got all involved with
which is that this this new study
confirms or says the universe is 26
billion years old oh yeah and I talked
about this with Joe on his show and it's
really one guy who I know he's a nice
guy in Canada and he came out with some
model that seems to suggest that yeah in
certain circumstances you could you
could have a universe that's older it
would be needed to be older in order to
explain the properties of galaxies that
are much much younger too young young in
a universe that's only 13 billion years
old and for people following out there
we basically go up the scale solar
system galaxy universe so he's looking
at the whole sh clusters and galaxies
between that and then the universe so he
was looking at really as you look back
in space you're looking back in time so
light uh the only good thing about you
know using imperial units of feet and so
forth is that light travels one foot
every nanc so I'm seeing you you're 3T
away I'm seeing you not as you are
instantaneously right now I'm seeing you
three Nan seconds ago you look very
young and very vital and very healthy um
but uh but it's not instantaneous so as
you look back to the curtains behind you
those are six feet away so it's six n
you keep going go past you know New
Jersey Manhattan go all the way back to
the the center of the Milky Way go
beyond the Milky Way go to the local
super cluster eventually you're going to
get back to where there's nothing in
your way no buildings no planets no
asteroids no galaxies and there you're
seeing back to when the earliest
galaxies themselves are being formed if
they exist and what he what this uh
regenda Gupta at University of Ottawa
said was well based on my calculations
one person's calculations you know
bolster by you know he didn't make any
errors or blunders but he sort of came
to the conclusion that the Universe had
to be much older we'll talk about that
later because that is a a a proper
controversy that we can discuss um there
are others that say the universe is
infinitely old so he's even though it's
twice the age of the accepted universe
that goop does come up with it's still a
hell of a lot you know Young than an
infinitely old universe that this other
guy Eric learner had come up with about
a year before that thank you for
watching the video guys please hit that
subscribe button and check out this
clip's full podcast Episode by clicking
here or in the description below